-You know, here at "Late Night"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
composed --
[ Laughter ]
You know, because it's like
after six years, we [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Composed of jokes written
by a diverse team of waiters.
Guys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
As a result, a lot of jokes come
across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight white male,
it would be difficult
for me to deliver,
but we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so, we'd like to share them
with you now,
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
These are two of our writers.
That's Amber and Jenny.
-I'm Black.
-And I'm gay!
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, how this works is
I'll read the setups
to these jokes
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
After an absence of 13 years,
softball will return
to the Summer Olympics.
-So, finally, all my exes
will be in one place.
-Warner Bros. recently announced
that they're looking
for a Black director to helm the
upcoming Black Superman movie.
-Black Superman
is like white Superman,
except he also has
two other jobs.
-The state of Maine recently
started offering incentives
to encourage residents
to get vaccinated,
like gift cards to L.L.Bean.
-Said lesbians,
"Anh, I don't need
any formalwear."
-If lesbians buy formal
clothes at L.L.Bean,
where do they buy
casual clothes?
-At L.L.Bean Outlet.
-Ah.
"Essence" magazine
recently published a list
of the best skin care products
for Black skin.
-You can tell a good
Black beauty product
when it's locked
behind the glass.
-Huh, so that really happens?
-Yeah. And it's a shame because,
by the time they come help you,
your hair's already dried out.
-Wow!
How fast does it dry out?
-Faster than Jenny moves in
with someone.
[ Laughter ]
-New York's oldest lesbian bar,
Henrietta Hudson,
is undergoing
an extensive renovation.
-Instead of a pool table,
it will now have a bigger,
nicer pool table.
[ Laughter ]
-Bon Appétit magazine recently
published an article titled,
"It's Time to Give
Black Barbecue Culture
the Attention It Deserves."
-"Black barbecues deserves
attention, alright,"
said a white lady
calling the police.
[ Laughter ]
-Some parents in Ohio were angry
after a lesbian couple
were voted prom king and queen
at a local high school.
-Wow, wait 'til they find out
about the whole cast
of the school play.
-Hey, Jenny,
when you were young,
what was your favorite
afterschool activity?
-Daydreaming
about Debbie Gibson.
-Huh. And was she popular
with young lesbians?
-I mean, she did wear
a pork pie hat.
[ Laughter ]
-That, she did.
Producers have announced
that former Food Network star
Paula Deen
will become a judge on the
upcoming season of "MasterChef."
-Fulfilling Deen's lifelong
dream of being called "Master."
[ Laughter ]
-Former "Bachelor" star
Colton Underwood
announced, in a recent
interview, that he is gay.
-"Yeah, that's what
'bachelor' means,"
said your grandparents.
-Did your grandparents have
a favorite bachelor?
-Mm-hmm, Liberace.
-Oh, mine, too.
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-No. I don't think I should.
-Oh, come on, just one!
-Guys, I just don't think
it'll end well.
-Do it!
-Okay, but only
because I trust you both,
especially after this
difficult year.
[ Laughter ]
A student newspaper in Buffalo
recently published an article
titled "Am I Dressed
Like a Lesbian?"
Well, if you put that much
thought into how you're dressed,
then, no, you're probably not.
-[ Gasp ]
-Seth!
-How dare you!
-You told me it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-Argh! Black women
and lesbians are liars!
♪♪